i've i've i've gone around and spoken
that
a large proportion of my
audience has been
young man you know under 30
something like that
and
i've spoken to them a lot about
responsibility
and what's so odd about about this is
that
of all the things that i've spoken about
because i can see the audience and i can
feel how the audience is reacting
because i'm always paying attention to
all of you it's in so far as i can
manage that so i i get some sense of how
what i'm saying is landing you know what
you have to do if you're going to speak
effectively to people and what what
happens is if i talk about
responsibilities everyone be is
silent just like they are now silent and
and not moving right focusing attentive
say
pick up your responsibility pick up the
heaviest thing you can and carry it and
the room goes quiet and everybody's eyes
open and i think
that always makes me break up
i was
[Applause]
i don't i don't know why i was speaking
to
an english journalist today who's going
to write an article in spectator
magazine i was talking about this and at
the same point in the discussion the
same i had the same emotional reaction i
don't really understand it
it's i think it's something there's
something about it that's so crucial
because
you know we've been fed this unending
diet of rights and freedoms and there's
something about that especially
there's something about that that's so
pathologically wrong and people are
starving for the antidote and the
antidote is
truth and responsibility right and it
isn't it isn't because that's what you
should do in some you know in some
some i know better or someone knows
better for you what you should do since
it's that it's not it's that it's that
that's the secret to a meaningful life
and without a meaningful life then all
you have is suffering and and nihilism
and despair and all of that and
self-contempt and and that's not good
and so the man it's necessary for men to
stand up and take responsibility and
they all know that and and are
starving for that message and and the
message is more that that's also a good
thing to stand up and take
responsibility because you're cursed so
much now from from from from when you're
young with this notion that your active
engagement with the world is part of
what is destroying and undermining the
planet and adding to the tyranny of the
social systems it's like how about not
so much of that hey because it's it's
it's just too soul deadening it's
anti-human right to the core and my
sense instead is that you know if you
if you were able to reveal the best of
yourself to you in the world that you
would be an overwhelming force for good
and that whatever errors might be made
along the way would wash out in the
works and that's the other thing that
you see in the abrahamic story is
because abraham is not a perfect person
by any stretch of the imagination he's a
real person and he makes mistakes but it
doesn't matter the overarching narrative
is you know maintain your covenant with
god and despite your inadequacies then
not only will you prevail but your
descendants will prevail it's like great
that's really good news you know so it's
been really something to see that in the
in the stories
how do you get motivated well one way to
do that is if you are good at
subjectively attaching dopamine to the
pursuit just knowing okay i really am
hungry for this i'm just i'm gonna tell
myself that you know making you know
making it one percent of the way is a
success and i'm gonna keep going and i'm
gonna keep ratcheting on and that's
great if you can do that but for people
that can't do that understanding this
relationship with the pleasure pain
balance can be more powerful just
understanding the more friction and pain
that you experience the greater the
dopamine reward you will get later and
that serves as its own amplifier of the
whole process of pursuing more dopamine
richard pryor in that movie and that the
kid has everything and he's the he's the
epitome of the spoiled brat all the toys
all the cars all the things now we see
this with people who actually go from
rags to riches and then bathe in all
their the luxuries they didn't have as a
child these are often the athletes that
don't go on to perform well again
these are people that crash because of
other dopamine seeking behaviors you
know i'm not going to call out names but
there are far too many examples of these
and i don't call out names mostly
because we are all capable of this we
all would like to think that oh if i had
all that money or if i had all that
success i would really be a good human
being and i wouldn't do those things
anyone any human being that is immersed
in these dopamine circuits too much or
who gets too much pleasure without
having to pursue it first and really
work and
actually experience pain pleasure
ratcheting back and forth along that
climb because it wasn't just dopamine
like this for you it was probably pain
pleasure pain pleasure pain
pleasure pain right they're always
proportional to one another
so anyone that does that it has a
tremendously hard time accessing
pleasure
they can't do that and and we often
think about the extremes of addiction
and those are really severe but we also
have to think about the more subtle
forms of something we really love but
indulging in it just a little too often
so that it no longer has that edge
you know there have been really good
studies of people who jump out of
airplanes with parachutes you know
i'm sure it's a lot of fun it looks like
a thrill but people do it over and over
and over again
often die
doing other things they often become
drug addicts because it's a huge high oh
yeah yeah a lot of that
and you know there are a lot of examples
of this i mean you can get addicted to
anything the key is to regulate that
behavior
[Music]
you